oscar-winner jared leto he is one busy
man with a movie also in the works
Jared's really sinking his teeth into
his role as a vampire in his next movie
Morbius due out in 2020
it's a crazy one I mean Morbius is it's
been life-changing to say the least but
the thirty Seconds to Mars frontman has
a personal stake in another project his
documentary a day in the life of America
debuted at the Tribeca Film Festival
this year
shot on the 4th of July in 2017 jared
directed the feature that's a
provocative companion piece to his
band's last album america we had about
92 crews we sent to every state in the
country we film for 24 hours the footage
that we got back is absolutely
mind-blowing it's insane violence
America and all his glory I was in a
helicopter shooting filming at sunset
Los Angeles on the 4th of July
while he hopes to do more projects like
a day-in-the-life during production
Garrett told us this experience was
deeply personal and inspiring I have to
say this country's filled with a lot of
really incredible people and you know we
look at the news and we see divisive
nough Swee see conflict and there's also
a lot of unity out there I think people
are optimistic when people have hope and
dreams for the future what a day it's
been July
[Music]